G E DURING HISAM
NTE S PILI UP.
BETWEENE MANCHIN ESITIL LST CL
CH TRNLSTH
T DEFIREAG
E TOP OF THECHD SC FLO GGIRATIO
THE CENTEFRASTRUCTUREBILLT  OF
TOD LOOKFFTH
WHEN CONES
BI BILLS SAVING SOCIAL CURITYG I
REDUCING AIHE AUTHORS OF TH
LS WERE
NE
DRION REHEAR000sUSE IT VICIOUSLO
PARTIES.
THE D.R.E.A..
THEYE OL OF THE SATD WA GOVERNI
IT
PARTISAN.F TH19
CHANGED THE REPUBLICANTY WASHINP
MODEL OFN IS
SWIMMING AGAIN. M DON'T G,  FOR
HASH OF
ONED TN SHINGTATS A REALPO
REPUBLICANS G TENTRTY.
ASOK , IN 2BIY RBS.SUBURBAN VOTR
OFF B ISSUE
NS.
CTIG A BIG TENT PARTY IHARD
TOGETHER, INCLUDG LEWHOM YOUFODE
IRIT
FRANKLIN ROOSEVELTTION OO THE NE
LYNDON JOHNS ENLISTED THE UTH TS
WHEN BARACK OBAMA HAD  WITH ANOS
REMAJO PRIORITL THSOCIALNCLUDI
BILL WAS A
EITHER PARTY COULD HAV
IN THE PAST YEAR HAVE SIMILARLY
LOFF IN D AGAINST MAKING
LOTS, BUNDING
THEY'LEXTENDED. VIEW WE SHOUL
E  SHE OFSS FUELS UNT
WEST VIRGINIA,
HAPPENS TO BE ANE READ
RE WE E DA
TANTLYHAREPRESENTS STATE
2020.
THS SURELY T
THEM, EE